[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum first i want to say
thanks for listening got a great guest
ethan sipley
uh today uh been in everything we'll get
to that in just a moment i'll make this
brief but i want to thank everybody out
there for thanking me and wishing me
happy thoughts on my birthday and also
having surgery i had a little back
surgery well first happy birthday
thank you for the happy birthday happy
belated birthday thank you my friend uh
the back is is doing better
good uh you know it's three weeks out so
thank you for everyone for
worrying about me or thinking about me
so that's all i'll say about that
and uh hey if you're if you enjoy this
podcast today if you're here for ethan
sipley and you're interested
hopefully you'll stick around we've got
a lot of great guests coming we've had a
lot of great guests in the past
hopefully you'll subscribe and uh you'll
you'll give it a listen and give it a
chance and that's how we get more
listeners hopefully you're here for
ethan but you stick around for
little old me uh ryan it's uh
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook to follow us
ad inside of you pod on the twitter um
i'd appreciate you writing a
review on apple um and listening
watching subscribing
uh telling everybody you know also uh
we'll talk about it at the end of the
show
but i talk about my wonderful patreon
you can join the family that supports
the podcast even more
it really helps it out you'd be
surprised by how much it helps out but
that's
patreon.com inside of you
and you could be part of my family and
i'll give you a text you a message after
you join
um also uh we have some two stages shows
july 31st
my band sunspin you go to sunspin.com
and get
all the information for the band merch
buy zooms and talk to me
and uh get tickets for the concert on
july 31st we're playing two shows it's
always a lot of fun
uh you can also go to the inside of you
store and get lex luthor stuff
small the lunch boxes lex luthor shirts
uh inside of you mugs
yeah the list goes on and uh sunspin.com
you get all the merch and
everything you want there also i will be
at uh dragon con in atlanta september
fourth weekend with tom willing
we're gonna probably do a smallville
nights i think i'm not sure yet
lexingtoncomicon.com
september 9th through the 12th and west
virginia mountaineer
comic con.com you can go to september
24th weekend uh i'll be there there's
other ones as well so just uh
follow me on the socials right now ethan
suplete is the guest today
he talks about everything his heroin
addiction how he had to go to uh
rehab how his wife helped him love life
make life matter
if you will um how he dropped out of
school um
how he nailed his first audition and so
much more this guy's an inspiration i
love him dearly
let's get inside of ethan sipley it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
well you know look dude i i haven't seen
you in quite a while and i know
we were kind of friends we were friends
you know like more acquaintances but
like not
close friends but back in the days when
i would hang out with you know at leo's
house
name drop total name drop right there
but and i
remember it was just a good time and he
was a great guy you're
you were always so pleasant so sweet so
and i remember
something funny because i have a video
of you and jay ferguson's
blue truck and we're singing sting and
you're singing it in one car and i'm
seeing it in the other car
oh wow do you remember that song god
it's just been on my mind
this was the 90s this was these were the
90s how would i remember
20 years ago yeah but i remember it i
remember and i remember just
uh enjoying your presence and then
seeing your whole
metamorphosis or whatever you're just
evolution has been just [ __ ] like
what the f like it's just incredible i
know that every podcast you do and i
know you have your podcast american
glutton podcast
which in california you think they
should have an american gluten podcast
they probably do but by the way what so
what what do you do on the podcast on
american glutton podcast
it's really you know um uh
another guy who who you will remember
from back then kevin connolly
um we were going to japan
like maybe 10 years ago and we got on
the plane
and he was like what the hell are you
going to do for 14 hours
and i said i'm going to listen to this
dan carlin podcast about you know the
history of the mongols or something
whatever it was some series where you
got
14 hours of content from dan carlin
who's like the god of history um
and he was like what's a podcast so i
showed him he downloaded the app
he didn't sleep on the plane he listened
to the whole thing straight through
we landed in japan and then the entire
trip we were on
he was consumed with podcasts and just
like
couldn't believe that this existed and
that people were just
talking and having conversations and and
so
he became kind of obsessed and he
created this podcasting
studio um called the action park media
and he before before they launched he
was kind of
saying to me you have to come do a
podcast
uh he wanted me to do one about
politics because i'm very much a
contrarian
and i kind of uh overtly despise all
politicians so no matter what anybody's
happy about in politics i'll just try to
ring [ __ ] down on it
and i said to him there is no way
that i'm gonna do that it's such like a
not a
thing to do because i have that
conversation with you
but it's not a public conversation it's
not anything i'm interested in
talking about publicly um and he was
like
come on push like one day i woke up
when he was asking me and i was like oh
i can fully talk about health and
fitness because i've done that
and it a lot of the way i look at it is
very analogous to how i look at politics
for philosophy or any of these things
um so we talk about health and fitness
but if anybody wants to
like listen to it
and you can very easily figure out that
i am just not interested in the
political system that we have
right and also there's enough shows
about politics
and when you talk about health and life
and in my show we talk about anxiety and
facing adversity and this and that and
uh it's something that
some people can relate to and politics
is just something that everybody just
starts arguing about and everybody has
their own opinion and
health is something you know health is
something that's universal and that i
think anybody could listen to so it just
it makes more sense
i think you'd be you're probably happier
than you would be if you're doing a
political
uh podcast yeah i mean um i would
yes for sure because i i you know
it's i don't think it's fun i think it's
a fun conversation to have with somebody
who
you know at the end of it even if they
get mad at you
they're not going to like write you off
as a bad person right
you can't i can't do that um with the
with
pup i don't think anybody can like i
think it's
it's a divide that's set that uh once
you're on
whatever line you're on and i don't even
believe in
in the left right line so much but just
like
whatever team you somebody associates
you with
some team and if that's not your team
[ __ ] you yeah so it's like it's just not
a
and and at to your point like it's the
most over discussed thing
in america since biden got elected i
just have turned off the tv i'm like
okay
all right good i mean i turned off the
tv many years ago
i think the last time i voted was obama
the first round and then i became so
disillusioned by him and his foreign
policy that i was just like
i'm done i quit i'm no longer interested
in american biology you start to think
does it matter anymore
does it really matter what i say or what
i do and how much
breath am i wasting exactly and i'm not
what if i'm
i'm not trying to convince anybody of
anything right you know
you just get tired of it all right you
know on this podcast i talk
you know right now this is called uh how
you doing it's a it's a mental health
moment
so how are how are you right now how are
you mentally
physically and what are you doing right
now to kind of keep uh
positive yeah so i'm in mexico
uh i have four kids
um they all go to school in other states
so i don't see them a lot and then we
had this awful thing the pandemic so
they all came home and it was like
like christmas groundhog's day of
christmas
over and over where it's like they're
all here this is
kind of fun and then you know and then
you get sick of them
at some point you're kind of like i wish
they'd go back to school but none of the
schools are open
um but having spent the last year
so in such tight family mode
it's very rough to be away from them
and so uh i'm trying just to concentrate
on work
and it's also proven quite difficult to
um adhere to my nutrition plan a hundred
percent from the hotel
uh and i have a little kitchenette in my
hotel and and
um that's super helpful but it's not
nearly as convenient it's not
a full kitchen and you know like i walk
to the grocery store
basically every morning before work and
buy food
and then make sure i have food to take
to work with me because i just don't
trust
set food um so that's
what that's how i'm doing right now so
you're a little anxious there's some
anxiety there you miss your family miss
your wife you miss the kids
you're in a different uh country you're
trying to work you're trying to have the
same regimen that you've been doing for
a while that's kept you in this great
shape this new person that you've become
uh so that's that's stressful because
you want to maintain that you don't want
to get off the wagon right
yeah there's a fair amount of anxiety
right now for sure
and so it's important for you to keep
your workouts if you stop working out if
you stop doing these things that's
probably going to come back
yeah the workouts are key and then we'll
have night shoots which kind of decimate
the workout because
uh you know you just spin up all night
and so like
leading up to the night shoot like the
night before the night or the day before
the night shoot i'll get
i'll my workout will be perfect and then
night shoots start and it just is like
almost too hard to go to the gym before
work the next day especially if your
turn around is
um i don't want to work out i don't want
to eat i i don't want to i just want if
i could eat and go to bed i don't
it's easy to jump into that room service
and i want to turn on hbo max
and you know or netflix or something and
relax and it's okay to do that once or
twice but if you continue to do it and
get into the habit that's where that
the bad habits again start that's right
well you know everybody knows you i mean
look if you
if you don't know him you've seen him in
everything american history x remember
the titans
wolf of wall street without a paddle uh
we worked with our buddies dax and uh
kevin smith films and my name is earl
and it just goes on and on you've been
working so long
but if you go back to you know i think i
always think it's interesting
to you know because my my family i
always talk about the dysfunction and
how it happened how i became an actor
and you know people know that
who listen but for you what was it like
growing up in your household because i
read that your parents
met in summer stock theater and so they
were actors
and so you grew up with two actors right
uh well they
quit uh acting when i came along
they were they they met in summer stock
they toured with shows my mom was on
broadway
and then uh i think it was a decision
where
they sat down when she was pregnant with
me and were just like
this is not a conducive lifestyle to
have kids and they were both actors i
don't know how
and i'm sorry if your uh significant
other
if you have one i don't i'm alone i'm
alone okay good
i'm very alone i don't understand two
actors
in a relationship like it just doesn't
the the relationships that i've been
aware of where that's the
that's the dynamic they don't seem to be
cohesive and then i think about like ed
harris
i guess he's got a solid long-term thing
with jackson kristen seemed to be solid
yeah yeah there are examples right
certainly they're rare they're rare
yeah and my parents kind of recognized
that and
they weren't doing movies it was all uh
theater but they would
tour and so one would be off on a tour
with one play and the other would be
either in new york or on some other tour
and um
you know they just they they opted out
but
uh so but i was raised with plays
and i had cats named stanley and stella
growing up and
like you know right right i mean
what did they just decide when you were
born like we're not gonna act so they
got real jobs and what were those jobs
and how did they
support you uh my dad is a
painting contractor and my mom ran that
business
and they've been running that business
since you were a kid yep
do you talk to them about projects
you're gonna do it maybe at your house
do you
ask for their uh input i mean i tell
them when they're stuff
i think there's a lot of um anxiety
about
work as an actor as you would know
and so i remember when i was first
starting out
and i had gotten this job and i was
thrilled about it and my dad said you
know you're only as good as your next
job
and it was just kind of like [ __ ] great
okay well that's
uh i don't have a next job so i'm
not i'm worthless um so there is
definitely
something and then about you know stuff
falls through and
and stuff uh falls apart you know
financing goes away
so i i actually don't like to talk about
it
with them at all until i'm like on set
and and it seems like they're not going
to pull the plug at any minute
right yeah because i remember you know
and i've told the story but i remember
my dad
i told him i'm doing this movie it's
this uh he goes what kind of movie is it
well it's an independent independent
what do you mean independent
well it's an independent movie it's you
know private financing
so it's not a studio picture it's not a
real movie
no i didn't say it wasn't a real [ __ ]
no it's a it's a real movie it's just
that it
hopefully will get bob oh [ __ ] it you
know what i mean
it was one of where you just you talk
yourself into feeling
like it's a shitty thing yes that's
exactly what it
is i start to talk like i'm just like
negative like this isn't a good thing
like oh i got a movie but
i'm not on set yet uh it's not a real it
probably won't go anywhere it's like
what are you doing
he's supposed to be having fun this is
the way things were supposed to be you
were supposed to graduate high school
and
you became something you did things this
is this is good but
i always think like that and i'm trying
look i'm trying to change that
positive thinking and therapy and things
like that but were your parents
supportive
did did they try to get you away from
acting or did you have the bug because
you were around them and you knew so
much about plays and
and did they kind of just say all right
this is what you want to do
i think my parents were just happy that
i was
doing something um there was not
i i left school at 14 and i was uh
what do you mean you left school at 14
who just says i'm leaving school at four
i just refused to go i just stopped
going
you know and and basically said to my
mom like are you gonna call the truant
officer
and send me to jail and i and she wasn't
prepared to do that and i just wasn't
i just no longer went um
and had some some arrests and
um you were arrested yeah i
yeah i was how old in the 80s
in the late 80s very young um
i was a pain in the ass and so
you know i had a friend who who was an
actor
and he had seen me in a play at school
at when i was like 14 right at the end
and he's
and he was aware that i was doing
nothing and left school
and said to me like you should come to
my acting class you should just do that
like this guy needs something to do and
where is this where is this
all in la all in la so you went to this
acting
class went to this acting class for a
year
from 16 to 17
kind of got frustrated with the acting
class
uh and then was like i'm gonna go
and you know there were levels there was
like the the beginner's class
right and then there was the
intermediate my friend was in the
advanced class so i always was like
i gotta get to the advanced class with
my buddy that'll be fun never got past
the beginner class
and quit and just started working you
know
like taking uh what was the magazine
backstage
and sending agents my picture and then
the agent's like
you look interesting i'll send you out
on an audition we'll see what happens
what first that's rare my first day of
auditions
i had melrose place and boy meets world
i went to melrose plate no i went to boy
meets world first
then driving to melrose place i was told
i had a call back for boy meets world
after melrose place go to melrose place
get a call that i got the job but then
they're discussing it and they're like
oh he's not
in sag we're not hot we're not gonna
hire him go back to boy meets
world and get boy means world which i
did for three years that was day one of
auditioning
uh day one this is the most bizarre
crazy start to a career i mean you hear
about these things
but these are incredibly rare things
this is a kid who says [ __ ] school
i'm done with school oh yeah i'll take
an acting class [ __ ] that i'm not taking
an acting class
i'll do it myself i'll send pictures to
backstage
and then you land a job on your first
day of auditions yeah
and you were on that show for three
years and you're starting to make money
yeah and i think at that point
uh my parents were just utterly relieved
were you in good spirits like it sounds
to me like you were problematic like you
were
troubled and you like i don't know how
your attitude was but did you have
like a bad attitude this whole time or
you were just kind of going with the
flow or
could you turn on the good charm um i
had a bad attitude with myself i had a
bad attitude with my parents
um but at work i was i was thrilled to
be at work i was thrilled to have a job
that um that was fun it was fun thing to
do
right were you heavier at this time
already yeah
so you were i got bigger over time i
remember between
season one and season two of boy meets
world um
my agents called and said the producers
say you do not
have to gain weight for this role
and and i
didn't think through that comment as
clearly as i should have because i was
just like okay
all right i don't have to gain weight if
i don't but i maybe i want to
well i didn't i didn't have that maybe i
want to i just had like well i'm not
you know i wasn't getting on scales i
wasn't aware that i was gaining weight
but i was i was steadily gaining weight
right
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help online therapy
and uh you know i've been talking about
these guys they've been a sponsor for a
long time for a reason because they're
helping people they're helping people
like ryan they're helping people like me
they're helping people like you
out there who don't have someone to talk
to someone who could be objective and
someone who could uh
help you out when you're going through
some struggles and we all need that
we're human beings
as we begin to see the light at the end
of the covet tunnel a lot of people are
still feeling down
um and emotionally out of sorts i would
say that is
is you know and what's to come and how
are we gonna you know we see the light
now at the end of the tunnel things are
opening up but there's this other strain
there's other things going on in life
and that we can't really control and
that's the thing you can't really
control life you can only control so
much
look you may not be feeling depressed or
at a total loss
but if you're feeling a little bit off
or your relationships are suffering
this could be a sign you should talk to
somebody in online therapy
can help ryan is it helping you it is it
does help to have the
the third party uh to sort of bounce
things off of and then
yeah you say things out loud and uh i
think it helps i didn't think you'd ever
do it i thought you were the kind of guy
that's kind of reserved that you know
oh that doesn't always uh build wealth
guys that's what i'm saying
you're a human being damn it uh all you
do is
fill out a questionnaire to help better
help assess your needs and match you
with a professional
licensed therapist you start
communicating with your therapist in
under 48 hours which is amazing
schedule secure weekly video phone or
even live
chat appointments therapists have a
broad range of expertise that may
not be locally available in your area
all you do is log into your account at
any time you send a message to your
therapist
boom that's it and if you don't like
your therapist you get a new one
that quickly better help is committed to
great matches so it's easy and free to
change therapists
if you need it's more convenient and way
more affordable than in-person therapy
and financial aid is available and i'm
one to tell you that
you get a therapist out here in la you
just
you might as well get a second job um
but betterhelp is very affordable and
today
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside betterhelp online therapy
we all need therapy folks go to
betterhelp and they're going to take
care of you
inside of you is brought to you by paint
your life you know ryan
it's so hard to be unique to give a
unique gift to someone
something thoughtful i usually go last
minute you go to somewhere in the mall
and you
grab something or from the cvs or
whatever you do
and it's not that meaningful people like
oh thanks a pair of socks
you know and it gets old and if you want
to show someone you really care about
them
paint your life is pretty pretty
brilliant you know i i sent my grandma
something
when i heard that at paintyourlife.com i
thought this is actually a great idea
so it's so inexpensive too it's
ridiculous
you give them a picture any picture that
you like me it was my
grandmother and myself sitting on a in
front of a door
at my old house in indiana where i grew
up and uh
they have the artist go to work and for
a very
incredibly affordable price you could
send a piece of art
to grandma paint your life man
if you want to give a truly meaningful
gift you've got to try
paintyourlife.com get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from
any photo at a truly affordable price
choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until every
detail is perfect
user-friendly platform lets you order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes
it's a quick and easy process get a
hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks yeah send a picture any
picture yourself your children
family a special place or a cherished
pet or combine photos into one painting
make the perfect birthday
more perfect uh make a anniversary
better
or a wedding gift you could do so much
with these things meaningful personal
and they could be cherished forever and
my grandmother was just flabbergasted
she just was like this is so sweet who
did this
how how did you do this you took the
time you did this yourself didn't you
and i'm like yes i did but i didn't
because i had someone do it
and paint your life at painterlife.com
there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded
guaranteed yeah and right now is a
limited offer limited time offer get 20
percent off your painting folks
that's right 20 off and free shipping to
get this special offer it's so simple
you just text the word inside
to 64 000. that's it inside
to 64 000 texts inside to 64 000
paint your life celebrate the moments
that matter most
terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com terms again
text inside to 64 000. inside of you is
brought to you by
untuck it i love untuck it
and you know me that's why you know
i love untuck it the reason i love
untuck it
is because when i go to a party or a
barbecue or whatever i always
you know whenever i try to dress up my
button-down shirts they're down to my
knees
and uh it just you know they're like and
i always wondered i thought gosh why are
all these shirts so long maybe because
they're used to being tucked into pants
not anymore untuck it you've done it
you've done it
untuck it summer's here and there's
never been a better time to try a shirt
from untuck it and the reason they're
great is because they're fitted to you
they won't hang down to your knees
they look nice you look presentable
anywhere you go anytime
they have performance shirts that wick
sweat also short sleeve button downs and
polos are made to beat
the heat look at this wonderful shirt
i'm wearing doesn't this look good and
it's comfortable and i could wear it
anywhere
and it's affordable and that's why i
like untuck it
use code inside for 20 off your first
purchase at untuckit.com untucked shirts
are perfect as we transition back to the
things we've been missing like dinners
with friends
reuniting with family and vacations too
by the way
untuck it ryan offers up to size triple
xl
plus they have slim relaxed and tall
fits and 85 stores nationwide
wow free returns and exchanges
untuckit.com for 20
off use the code inside use code inside
for 20
off your first purchase at untuckit.com
do you think that had something to do
with being a 14 year old in high school
did you feel like the way people were
treating you or the way do you think
that's
sort of how that whole how you just
you're feeling
how you felt about things and your
parents trying to tell you did they ever
say hey
you lose some weight or you need to like
you know when you hear these
yeah explain that i was on diets from
five uh until basically
until um until i just started telling my
parents to [ __ ] off
uh which was like 14. um
and uh i was you know
it was uh there was a
sense of um wrongness
my first my first idea of self you know
you're a little kid
and there's no idea that like oh this
body
like there was no awareness of it the
first bit of awareness that i had about
my body was that it was wrong
uh and and so
and then i was just and then it was just
constantly reaffirmed
through you know my whole family would
go
macrobiotic but really it was just
because they they thought this macrobite
you know and you can name any diet um
atkins at some point in the 80s and and
fit for life and it there were adele
davis books which she was like the first
diet person i was ever truly like here
we're gonna read this book together and
you're seven
and i'm like okay um
but there was just a constant feeling of
being
off from like five on uh
and so when i just kind of
got sick of it and was like i'm not
gonna conform to
what i'm not gonna do what you tell me
to do anymore
um you know i went
like like a runaway train
down the road away from the goals they
were setting for me
well because you know it's those
developmental stages it's like that
young
five six seven that little
that i remember you're short you're you
know
you're you're not smart you're those
things stick with you no matter how
smart
you get or how tall you get you always
remember
for some reason i wish i could just stop
that little [ __ ]
from thinking these things that you
weren't good enough you weren't smart
enough you weren't whatever
but you're saying ultimately that at
that young age
you're like what's wrong with me
ultimately like
i and and does that carry with you
throughout your adulthood like even
though you're in great shape now you
look great you feel great
do you still think back i'm still that
kid
you know it's a very um tricky thing
because i don't know
i can i can mentally work myself through
it today
but there is always kind of my
my gut reaction to myself in the mirror
or a photograph or anything like that
is always kind of discussed and
and as of today i can definitely stop
that because i know that's a dark road
if i allow myself to sit in that so i
take time and i find
something about myself that i'm not
disgusted by
and i build on that and then i feel a
little bit better
and but yeah there there there's no
like true escape from there's no like
off switch where it just goes away i
haven't found that for myself
right um you know and you think about
like even
some injuries physical injuries you
break your arm and then you're always
kind of aware that that arm might be
weaker or something like that
um it's it's similar it's not as heavy
as it was
at one point and and there was a long
time where i used drugs to
to block out those thoughts and and i
suddenly
you know had never understood this sense
of confidence that
drugs gave me and it was just like well
this is [ __ ] great
if i can just do this all the time but
then you know you wake up
and you feel like even worse worthless
yeah
yeah so that was kind of a trap for me
too um
it is something that i can work through
but it hasn't it's not something i've
cured
right also at this young age you start i
guess 17 years old you start getting
rolls
and that doesn't stop you don't stop
working you haven't stopped working
but you're starting to get rolls and
you're
playing you're heavier on all the rolls
correct
yeah so do you start to feel like why
lose weight anyway why try to change who
i am because i'm getting all the jobs
now
you know it was something that by the
time
uh i guess like i did boyle meets world
for
three years and so i'm like in that time
period i started doing drugs while i was
doing drugs i was not thinking
about any of it nothing there were no
thoughts like that it wasn't
i wasn't thinking about the future at
all it was just
very much in the moment and the moment
is numb and comfortable
and um and so there was no thought about
like
if i lost weight there was no thought
about weight it was just like
i i i have this crippling
uh disgust for myself that uh
that i can turn off with drugs and if i
do that
then i'm happy and i can be happy doing
all this other stuff that is supposed to
make you happy lots of money and
attention and
you know success to some degree um
so there wasn't a lot of thought about
the future what kind of drugs
heroin cocaine really you got into
heroin
yeah for a while for a few years yeah
i mean they they always say that that's
one drug you get on you never get off
for the most part
it's a rough one i i went to rehab a few
times and i
i remember being so envious of the
the crackheads at rehab because
they would come in and the first thing
you do is detox like
right you don't go to group if you're
still strung out um
you're like kind of off in another area
and these crackheads come in and they
just sleep
and then they they get woken up and they
go to meals and they eat
everything and they have these just huge
appetites and then they go back to sleep
and the junkies are sitting there awake
for days on end
can't eat anything pissing out their
asses like it's really rough
my god yeah but it's nothing as rough as
the the the ones that were envious of
the guys who came in
with like serious alcohol dependency or
serious um benzo dependencies because
those guys are at risk of
death like the other drugs are not at
risk of death when you're coming off if
it's not comfortable
it's miserable but like you see guys who
have like real
alcoholism um
you can die just quitting those drugs
right
i mean i read this article or something
that you quoted where you went into a
starbucks and you used to memorize
everything you're going to order to a t
explain explain that story paint that
picture
yeah i i still do that um you know there
there was a uh there was there was
always a feeling
of being in an imposition and and not
wanting any attention drawn to myself
and so in any interaction i would have
where other people were around i would
want it to be as efficient and smooth
and
quick as possible so i would never
stand online and then arrive somewhere
and make a decision
at that point the decision is made
before i get out of my car i basically
know
exactly what i want i know how to order
it i know where to pick it up i know
where to stand
so that i'm not in anybody's way while
i'm waiting for them to prepare it like
all of that is stuff that i'm
aware of um and then i would have
i would lash out at people who didn't do
that in my mind
going like how rude and presumptuous of
that person not to have figured it out
and so i would build up these
resentments but really it was all about
like
who [ __ ] cares dude we're getting
coffee like
you know if you arrive at the teller and
you and you notice like wow they've got
a
flavor of coffee i'm not familiar with
let me ask him about that like you have
the right to do that
right right i would never give myself
because i wouldn't want to spend another
moment because i picture
that arriving at that place you're
almost on a stage and i don't want to be
looked at in that context because in
that context i'm me
i'm not acting when i'm acting i'm not
mean so you didn't like to be noticed
you didn't like to be recognized you
didn't want people to say hey aren't you
that guy from whatever
you did not want that i didn't mind hey
are you that guy from whatever as much
and i'll tell you why
because that was a veil and a facade
that blocked them to some degree or
lessen their awareness to some degree
of seeing my grotesqueness does that
make sense
yeah so i mean i pictured myself moving
through society
as an eyesore as a burden
and if i could throw up things like
this identity actor that would distract
you from the burden that i'm presenting
that was fine so so in that sense i
didn't mind
simply because it was a distraction from
what i thought of myself
i mean that's just i mean it's horrific
to think that you know it's just it's
such a sad
thing that it almost takes in other
words people
noticing you from something is a
distraction of who you
think you are like you're it's it kind
of takes your their mind away from
who you believe you really are and
they're not seeing because they're
putting you on a pedestal in a sense
totally and that's what it was
um and that's probably still what it is
a little bit
uh today but you're unrecognizable
you're a different person like honestly
when i look at you
i don't know anybody who'd go well you
remember the titans weren't you in this
where are you because you look so
different
yeah it's such a dick it's very rare now
yeah
and you like that yeah i mean i like i
like anonymity i like
i i don't want to be looked at really i
i
i am pleased that i can show that
perseverance on a given course
can be successful because i failed so
many times at this course so
in that respect i'm happy to put a
picture up which but even that
there is something painful about social
media because
um it just i just am
so judgmental of myself
uh and and and it's bizarre now that i
can have
uh dueling ideas about myself especially
when you're trying to work on
musculature of being
too fat i can feel and i did today i
felt too
fat and too thin at the same time
and and i didn't know what to do with
this thought
um and this feeling and and it's just
like
you know at some point you gotta laugh
because it's like i i recognized that
there
will be no uh perfection there will be
no
turning off of the need of of change
right um so it you know it's just a
burden
and and i say all that it's gotten much
better sure
it is much better how easy is it for you
to i mean we we hinted at this but
for someone who had you know for for so
long what was someone else
you know in a way you were obese
and now you're in great shape and
working hard and you just feel great
how easy or how how easy would it be for
someone to fall off the wagon
is it something like alcoholism is food
something like alcoholism where
you know you get down about something
you you have loss you have whatever and
that just spirals you is it something
that you're aware of or you talk to
someone about
i talked to my wife about it but but i
don't i don't put
absolute restraints on food in the same
way that i do drugs and alcohol drugs
and alcohol
is a very either or for me
food the tricky thing is that you can't
stop eating
you die the end result of not eating is
death and so that's not a solution
that's never a solution
right and so you find a lot of diets
that will present you with
just quit this type of food and even
that
i was unsuccessful at because you game
that you can you can
if if the point is like look i
understand if you're
actually allergic to wheat or to gluten
and you have celiac or hashimoto's or
something of that nature
um yes you shouldn't deep gluten you got
to cut that out of your of your diet
but if you're if your goal is weight
loss
um and you and
you go about it by just removing gluten
from your diet
i i would just say from my anecdotal
experience
not successful it's not a successful way
to lose weight
we're not exploring in that instance
the way we were interacting with food
that got us to the point that we needed
to lose weight
at all we're just saying the bonus of
burden is on this thing
gluten which if you're obese if that's
the only issue you're dealing with
it's scientifically not gluten's fault
so there's a lot in that i don't like to
put
multiple days consecutive days
together of not sticking to my program
so the holidays
i'm not going to be the guy at christmas
dinner
weighing my roast beef and
yeah yeah horseradish yeah you want to
enjoy the holidays right
yeah but i'm not also going to pig out
on leftovers on the 26th
um so there's there's a little balance
there
this whole time too growing up i mean
did you date girls did you have like a
lot of dates were you
i mean is it something you always wanted
to date and you you couldn't keep her
i mean what was that what was that like
i definitely had
confidence once i was on drugs um
to talk to women strong and and i had a
few
i i definitely had interactions with
girls
um unfortunately a lot of the time i was
on
so much drugs that there would be an in
you you you're no longer effectual when
it comes to
doing that deed um so i i didn't have
any like really successful relationships
right uh before my wife um
who really was the spark that turned my
life around
um and uh
you know it was a weird cycle of like
i wasn't gonna talk to girls before i
did drugs because i
i thought so lowly of myself or if i was
gonna talk to girls it was gonna be i
was gonna be the safest person they
could ever talk to you know what i mean
there's not gonna be a hint of sexuality
in my communication with them
yeah i just recognized that even back in
the day when i knew you was just so you
were kind of a
you know you talk you were funny but you
didn't you weren't going on hitting on
girls you weren't you were just minding
your own thing and just hanging out with
the guys and just kind of
you know i i just remember that i do
remember that just uh you know one of
those top-notch guys
did you say your wife brandy who you've
been married to since 2006 right
we've been married since 2006 together
since 2002.
and she saved your life you say i i i
don't want to say she saved my life
i didn't care about my life prior to her
my life meant very little to me prior to
her
and once i started seeing her i was
newly sober i started seeing her
it was the very first time i started
thinking about
future and that was really how i clawed
my way
out of this pit was going like having
you know looking up and seeing the light
way up at the top like that there was
life until there
until then i didn't i never thought
about the future there was no thought i
went to bed so many nights
totally convinced i was gonna die in my
sleep and this was
nothing that sparked a huge change
wow yeah that almost makes me want to
cry
because it's yeah there's certain things
about it that i can
understand um but but having
not seen a future is perhaps the saddest
thing
there is if you don't see a future if
you just wake up every day
saying when is it gonna happen or when
am i gonna when when am i gonna be done
and i'm fine with it just
end it already it's almost like you know
and the fact that someone comes into
your world and for the first time your
eyes open wide and you're thinking
hey wait a minute there there's a future
maybe there is a future maybe i'm worthy
of someone or someone's worthy of me
would you know what i mean it's it's
that's that's amazing that you meet
someone and not only that but you
probably
opened up to her and she had to see your
true colors
come out and see how you know damaged
you were or
not damaged but fractured or like you
know how much baggage or
[ __ ] you had weighing on you for your
entire existence
and at this point you realized i've
thrown everything at her and and did you
my question is did you throw everything
at her
and she's not running yeah the
the moment i i broke down and
and and
it was it was a very bizarre thing that
i don't even know
the adequate words to communicate
exactly
what occurred for me but i i had i had
this
i had this brutal conversation with a
guy
that was basically saying like you're
going to hell you need to lose weight
and i hadn't had a conversation like
that before it was it was like
so um curt
and and righteous
and i i landed in another country and i
was kind of like
in a state of almost shock and i and i
was like
also going like holy [ __ ] he's kind of
right about some things like i'm not
thinking about
anything but like immediate
gratification and i've got this girl
who i love who wants to do all these
things that i'm not
physically capable of doing like going
on a hike
or uh you know spending the day at the
beach or going to a museum like
i was not in really a state to do that
kind of stuff
and i remember thinking i gotta tell her
about this condition i have as as though
she wasn't aware
um and and it was the weirdest thing it
was like i got to tell her this secret
that's not a secret that she knew but
she's going uh hello
yeah but talking to her about it was
as though she didn't know it literally
felt to me in that moment
like i'm gonna say this to her and this
could be the end of us so it was either
it it felt very much like if i don't say
this to her
that i need help with this i lose her
for sure at some point
because her future
is a path that i'm not going to be able
to
keep up with and if i do say it to her
i risk exposing this truth to her
that is ugly and awful and
damaged and and so i just thought like
well at least i i'm taking a shot at
winning
there and so i had this conversation
with her and she was like
so [ __ ] cool dude she was like oh
yeah
we're gonna do that as soon as you get
back to l.a i'll have something ready
for you
and i was like oh okay and she was like
yeah and for right now
i was in romania and uh and she said for
right now
just while you're there just don't eat
bread and i was like
okay and that was kind of her it was she
was laying out this thing of like
you're gonna take a baby step in the
arena of being responsible with food
and it wasn't like don't ever eat bread
again just on this two weeks you're
gonna do
one thing that is going to be
your beating food and it's gonna be
you're gonna leave the dinner roll
you're gonna not eat sandwiches it's
very simple did you do it don't lose
weight
and i did and i made it two weeks or
three weeks or whatever it was with not
eating bread
and i landed in l.a and she picked me up
and she had gone to this nutritionist
and gotten this like
liquid diet thing and you know
the nutritionist gives you big bottles
of fiber pills and
vitamins and she individually bagged
everything like spent a whole day
preparing the stuff for me and she was
like i've made
each day of all your supplements and
your protein shakes
and all you have to do is just do this
and i was like great and i'll do it and
i did that for 60 days
a liquid diet i lost 80 pounds
and as far as roller coaster dieting
goes
that's 80 pounds that i've never dipped
back into i've never gotten
those 80 pounds were permanent weight
loss
um and then i got into you know and then
you go back to work and you're like
light-headed half the time and it's not
conducive so you have to eat and
and i would never recommend somebody do
a liquid diet from
whatever their morbidly obese until
their goal like i don't think that's
wise
but it was a great kickoff
inside of you is brought to you by geico
you want to listen to this because
geico makes it easy for all of us it's
everybody
knows the word geico you know the
company
they've been around forever and if you
rent your own home
or you you you own your own home it
doesn't matter
they can help you it's geico easy you
know it's easy
ryan bundling policy is a geico it's
true you know if you're tired of paying
someone
uh else rent uh someone else auto policy
uh you know you could have it all with
geico because you already have so much
to do we have so much going on in our
lives
and it just it just makes it easier i
don't like to go shopping so i use a
a company that does the shopping for me
i don't want to pay all these people
i make a geico easy and i they just pay
it for me is it it's that simple
and you want simple uh that's right
bundle your homeowners or renters
insurance along with your auto policy
go to geico.com get a quote and see how
much
you can save it's geico easy visit geico
today guys
geico.com today that's geico.com
inside of you is brought to you by
public wreck i'll tell you what the
sweatpants that i normally wear
are you're embarrassed to see them
outside of your house
most the clothes i wear you don't want
to be seen outside and i like to be
comfortable we all like to be
comfortable
but what's amazing about public wreck is
they have the clothes
that are way more comfortable than the
clothes i'm wearing and you can be seen
in them
isn't that sweet i could wear sweats
and feel comfortable because they're
good quality
and public wreck they make leisure wear
and waist and inseam sizes because
comfort starts with a better fit
their best-selling all-day everyday
pants are more stylish alternative to
sweatpants
and a more comfortable alternative to
jeans their clothing is great for
lounging at home looking sharp for work
heading to the bar and anywhere pants
should be worn ryan why do you like
public wreck
well they have sizing that makes sense
the all-day everyday pant comes in waist
and in-seam sizing so they fit
short guys tall guys and everybody in
between that's right and they're made
from a breathable
stretchy moisture-wicking fabric you can
wear them
24 7 and guess what they're going to
look brand new
this is like they made them for me and
they also made them for you
they also have zipper pockets so no more
having your phone or wallet fall out
when you sit down
they come in nine colors one for each
day of the week and then some
plus they've got incredibly comfortable
shorts t-shirts henleys polos hoodies
jackets
and even golf wear and they just
launched ryan
their women's line so now anyone listen
to this can enjoy public wrecks
game-changing fabric in their wardrobe
these are always the top choice
in my rotation of clothing for sure a
public wreck ryan
uh i've never had pants fit this well
right and now i don't feel sloppy yeah
that's my thing i usually feel sloppy
people like michael you could dress up a
little more
but you know what with public wreck i
don't have to do that i could like
well i can do that because i'm wearing
their clothing which is just as
comfortable as the clothing i'm wearing
but people go wow you look good dude you
look approachable you look approachable
you're put together and they commend me
for that ryan
so as the world is opening back up make
sure you've got clothes that are as
flexible as your life is
public wreck rarely discounts but right
now right now they have an exclusive
offer just for inside of you listeners
folks listen to this
you got to try this stuff go to public
rec
dot com slash iou that's public rec
dot com slash iou to receive ten percent
off that's public wreck
rec dot com slash iou for 10
off public wreck you know what's crazy
is
what i'm hearing is your entire life
you had many people talk to you about
your weight
and it was always i'm not listening to
you i'm not doing this
and someone comes along
and you're listening and that's i mean
you you knew something
this was the love of your life this was
somebody that you you for the first time
you saw a future and you listened to her
was
was she really the first person that you
were like all right someone's helping
someone's actually going on this journey
with me i'm not alone it was the first
time
that i was invested that it that i was
the one going like i want to change
it was not it was it was the very first
time it wasn't somebody going like
here's what you're gonna do
despite what you want um
and you know like is there a way that i
could have been invested as a kid if my
parents had used different language with
maybe i don't know but all i know is as
a kid
it was now you're gonna eat this way
and here's why because you're fat or
because you're overweight and it's not
healthy and all of this stuff
which just compounded how i felt
badly about myself um and
made me rebel and and and ultimately you
know
i got really bad when i became
autonomous and was making money and was
really just living for the moment and
doing whatever i wanted with no
restraint um
but yeah it was the first time i went
hey i need help with this i want to
change
i will do whatever you tell me which i
think i i've also had success being
sober in that way
um and and in talking to people about
sobriety like i have
no interest in my wife is not sober
and i have no interest in anyone um
in trying to make somebody sober like
this is not my mission
at all in fact to the point where i've
had people say will you talk to my kid
or will you talk to my friend
and it's like no because
any it didn't work for me and i don't
have the understanding of making it work
for somebody else by
pleading with them or describing some
utopian future by changing your behavior
um i know it works when the individual
goes
i want to make a change that's that's
how i've seen it work that's how i've
experienced it work
and so the kind of the same thing with
food i think if you asked yourself
for many years of your life if you know
that stupid question that people are
like that's such a stupid question when
you say uh
do you love yourself but it would have
been easy for you to say [ __ ] no i don't
it sounds like right for most of your
life i i could say that a lot of my life
i would probably say
what no no i don't i
sometimes i think i'm all right i
sometimes like myself i love myself i
[ __ ] how do you love yours that's a lot
to say i don't love anyone
it's just such a mind boggle that people
are like you should be able to say you
love yourself pretty easily
and that always [ __ ] with me because
it never was easy to go
yeah yes i love myself that's not
something that occurs
to me at all so when did you start
do you i mean do you now feel like
you're loving yourself more
i mean obviously i feel like it's been
very helpful to be responsible for other
people and
by doing that i have to be responsible
for myself
and and and and i do think i've
learned to have a certainly a higher
level of admiration for myself
especially when it's like um
setting and achieving goals and sticking
to things that i've made decisions about
because i was not good at that forever
so
this idea of love i don't know yeah it's
a very abstract thing
for me too you know but you love other
people when you love your kids you love
your wife
obviously yeah you know you're on an
airplane and they tell you like if we
have to do oxygen masks you got to put
your oxygen mask on
first because if you pass out trying to
put your kids oxygen mask on
then they don't get theirs either so in
that way
i think that's a road to loving yourself
right if you can yeah kind of play this
mental hopscotch a little bit where
you're like i have to treat myself
well because i have people dependent on
me and
and i actually love my wife
and the fact that she loves me and i and
i
i don't have a really a critical thought
about her
leads me to believe there's something
lovable about me you know it's
absolutely gymnastics that we have to
play absolutely
by the way before you started this big
diet which started you know losing
weight
what was the most you ever weighed the
most i ever weighed um
objectively where i saw it on a scale
was
536 but i did gain weight
from that point so i i say 550 which
14 pounds at that weight that could have
just been
a little extra salt one night and a
bunch of booze to get me up 14 pounds
but i did see 536 on a scale do you
sometimes look back and go
how did i survive how am i still here
yeah it's wild i mean there were there
were as i said
many nights that i was convinced i
wasn't gonna be here
um you know i think if i
if i make it if i make it to the average
lifespan
of an american i i'm going to be very
proud of myself
well dude i'm glad you're alive i'm glad
you're here you have a it's
such an amazing story and you're an
amazing human being and i'm glad you
know it gives me hope because a lot of
people hope that
you know you find love sometimes and you
find somebody who really loves you
inside out and accepts you for who you
are no matter what
and that that does a lot for your mental
well-being it does a lot for your soul
it's like when you can find someone just
like wow i cannot do and i've done i've
dated people where i try to do
see i told you i'd [ __ ] up see i'm a
[ __ ] up
see you should leave me and when someone
sticks around and says no
[ __ ] i love you and you know there's
i'm just you know i'm glad you're here
this is the uh it's
such a wonderful story and i like seeing
you succeed and i don't like putting
qualifications on and i feel bad because
i think
if there's a a single person out there
who's struggling with
this i don't want them to think like
they have to find
love in order to make some change
um and so i think about sobriety because
i did get sober
before i met my wife which was an
another it was a battle
and and i do think there is some truth
and when we when you're talking about do
you love yourself
finding something to at least respect
about yourself finding areas you
contribute to
others or whatever gives you that sense
of decency or um
you know the idea of belonging to a
group
whatever that group is whether it's a
family or a group of friends or a
business or
work or a [ __ ] video game online
community
whatever it is i think that everybody
can
spend a minute and and and locate some
way that they
have interactions with others and and
are contributing something even if
you're just saying hi and smiling at the
barista at your local starbucks
twice a week or something like this so i
i do feel bad sometimes talking about
uh myself and what i've gone through
in terms of brandy just because i don't
want
somebody to think like that's gonna fix
you yeah i have to find something right
it's been a shitload of work um
and i've gone back and forth it wasn't a
straight line
right and i don't i don't believe that
in order to make yourself better um
you have to have someone significant to
others so i i just want i just wanted to
add that on because
i do often feel that i i do believe that
everyone is capable of making some kind
of change
and and i don't think there should be
qualifications
well i've heard so many times people say
you can't love someone so you love
yourself so
um i think there's some truth to that um
yeah
you know i think you know sometimes i've
been in relationships from like you know
i'm just not good enough for you there's
just no way
and that's just all on me that's just me
going you're just not having
that love for yourself or that like dude
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
uh every day yeah i am definitely
not good enough for my wife and i am
very
pleased every day that i'm winning in
this
in this exchange i love that i love that
um you know i saw something on
on the internet you know you were it was
probably what you're doing now but you
were just
ripped up rat attack tatted um
it was a recent post and um your
sister-in-law juliette lewis name drop
said uh i'm sensing this guy is uh
what's the word evil uh so is that is
that the role you're playing
now yeah a lot of fake tattoos uh which
strangely
um many people on that post
thought that i had overnight gotten a
full
body and face tattoos and the whole nine
um and growing my beard like
they look good though those tats look
good yeah these guys are doing a great
job
hey really quick this is called [ __ ]
talking i'm just gonna ask you a few
questions from fans that could be fast
rapid fire um you know i'm interested in
this somebody
says uh you know connor walker do you
have any funny stories experiences while
filming the wolf of wall street
and on top of that my question was i
mean give me something what was it like
working with uh scorsese for god's sakes
um it was awesome it was
it was a lot of fun uh i
uh the only um funny weird story was
there there we were filming kind of two
different things and
and and me and the rest of the guys the
the brokers were kind of
off uh on a break and then i got a call
like you're needed on that closed set
and it was a close set like nobody's
allowed on this set
and and i was like i'm needed what am i
needed for
and then they were like you just have to
go in there and i went in and
somebody was like we can't figure out
how to do
cocaine up an [ __ ] can you help us
with this we heard you could help us
with
and i was like i'll do my best i mean
how do you do that it's almost like
sucking up a fart or sucking up air from
your [ __ ]
you you load it into a straw and then
you apply pressure to one end of the
straw and the cocaine comes out the
other
at the other end of the stream so you
help them i helped them but i'm just
saying
i was the guy called to
to be that's the guy on set that was
gone like
who can help us with an ethan does
that's when that's when you should have
known all right i got to get my [ __ ]
together that's it that's rock bottom
i've been sober at this point for almost
10 years so
okay you know some of the people
involved in that movie were
had known me prior and were like he
knows how to do this
get him well look man this has been
extraordinary i hope you enjoyed it i
just it's very inspiring to me and i
love hearing the story and it's just
um because i didn't know it it's like a
lot of times you know you and i haven't
had a conversation like this
ever and so if this is what it takes to
getting to know you a little bit more
and kind of knowing a little you know
inside your
what goes on inside your head and all
that but uh i really appreciate you
you coming on here thank you you're a
great conversationalist this was really
fun
oh dude thanks man this is great i
really love doing this and i have such a
dd that when i put the headphones on it
just it helps it just makes me just
listen and i'm sort of forced to listen
but it's it's very easy to listen to you
and you speak eloquently and um
well you have to do mine you have to
come when i get back to la you have to
come on mine and we'll talk about health
and fitness i'm in man i would love that
dude i love you all my best to you kick
some ass thank you
i loved ethan's story i thought it was
uh
you know a lot of people won't talk
about the things that they've happened
in their life
things that have happened in their lives
that are so
hard you know you know he went through
to go through heroin addiction to go
through you know most of his life he was
obese
and uh didn't love himself and didn't
like being recognized and
you heard all that and uh now he's an
inspiration you see the guy has
gotten his life together he's he's lost
so much weight he's uh strength but more
importantly i think is that he's
learning to love himself and that
shows you that he's capable of it it
wasn't really about the losing of the
weight it was just making sure that you
were okay with
you know with who you are yeah and uh
so that was pretty special so thanks for
listening again if you want to uh
follow the podcast ryan oh uh inside of
you pod on twitter inside to be podcast
on instagram and facebook
and please write a review please
subscribe if you really enjoyed this
today i
appreciate it you could also join the
wonderful patreon family that support
the podcast in so many ways and keep
this thing afloat really
uh there's different tiers where you get
boxes of merch and a letter
uh from me every couple of months and uh
get to ask
uh guest questions um there's so much
that uh the patreon involves and if you
join
go to patreon.com inside of you i'll
write you a message after and it's just
become such a great family i don't know
how many thank you
notes i've had i just got a nice email
from raj and gracie
um who are uh patrons um leanne um
so many people that write in and say god
i've become friends with so many people
on this thing and that's it makes me
just happy as a clam
uh also our don't forget our show is
july 31st 2 p.m and 6 p.m if you want to
hear my band sun spin
i really think we just came out with an
album i think you'll really enjoy it we
played two shows july 31st on stage
it.com
just type in sunspin or you go to
sunspin.com and you get all merch you
can book zooms
with me you could uh book the band if
you like some people have done that
before so that's always fun to come play
for people at a park or wherever we play
sunspin.com or handles please follow
sunspin band on twitter
uh instagram and facebook at sunspin
band we
need a few more hand a few more follows
we could use those so please everyone
listening please just really quickly
follow us uh on those handles at sunspin
band
i'll be at a lot of conventions coming
up i just got back from
uh houston it was wonderful i love the
people in houston i had a great time
that was comic palooza it was my first
con in quite some time but seeing
people made me happy uh also i'll be at
dragon con in atlanta september fourth
weekend with tom welling
lexington september 9th through the 12th
with tom willing
west virginia mountaineer com september
24th weekend
and the list keeps coming so uh also if
you want any merch
we got great stuff we got some funko lex
luthor pops funko pops
we got some uh lex luthor shirts to say
michael rosenbaum's the best lex luthor
i had those main people like them
uh lunch boxes small the lunch boxes
also tons of cool merch like
mugs and inside-y mugs and uh tons of
stuff like that so
i want to say thank you for that and
thank you again for for listening thank
you again for
uh supporting me especially during my
surgery and all the happy birthday
wishes once again
and uh couldn't do without it couldn't
do without ryan i'll tell you that much
couldn't do without him i'm gonna read
the top tier patreons these are the
people that contribute the most
on the patreon and uh they get shout
outs that's one of the special things to
get out so here we go
nancy d leah s tricia f sarah v little
lisa yukiko jill e brian h lauren g
nico p jerry w robert b jason w apophian
kristen k amelia o allison l raj c
joshua d
emily s cjp samantha n jennifer n stacy
l
carly h chan s jamal f janelle b carrie
b
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
tabitha 273
kimberly e mike e eldon supremo 99 moore
ramira santiago m sarah f chad w leanne
p
janine r ray a maya p maddie s shannon d
matt w belinda n kevin v james r chris h
dave h
samantha s spider-man chase sheila g
brad d ray h ray hi ray
uh tablet t tom n suzanne b liliana
michelle k
hannah b michael s talia m betsy d
hi betsy i messed her name up a few
times she loves it i do it on purpose
claire m liz j laura l chad l rochelle
nathan e marion e meg k janelle p trav l
dan n diane r and the final little list
here
it's not ojeda it's all jetta it's ajeda
agenda
lorraine g veronica k big stevie w
kendall t carol d
sandy b angel m yes i didn't shower
today if that's what you're wondering
where's my hat why is my hair greasy
just leave me alone
eric c rhiannon c cory k super sam emily
c
sherry s coleman g david c michelle a
liz l
jeremy see jeremy c
in class today andy t cody r
chris e sebastian k gavinator and h
elliott m john b
brandy d n yvore yavor i just sent you a
package giovore
yvore what's good name for your vore
it's either yaver i think it's yvore
yvore
sorry if i'm a boar yavor yavor
against it yvore or against it
uh that's it those are the lovable
patreons you can go to patreon.com
inside you get your name shout out and
much much more and uh
is there anything else really ryan
another fun podcast
it was a good podcast i really learned a
lot from it i learned a lot from these
guests i hope you do i hope you tune in
every week
and uh thank you for allowing me to be
inside of each and every one of you
i appreciate all of you sincerely and uh
ryan why don't we say goodbye to that
camera way up there
from the hollywood hills in hollywood
california yeah
brian taylor's over here with uh your
host michael rosenbaum
michael rules uh we appreciate you man
this is uh we have fun doing this it's
not
brain surgery but uh we hope you uh
stick around thanks
[Music]